y
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos al programa
los observadores de france 24 esta
semana comenzamos en la frontera entre
colombia y venezuela donde los civiles
son las víctimas colaterales de los
combates entre el ejército colombiano y
la guerrilla luego veremos como dos
inglesas han usado la red víctor para
concienciar sobre la vida cotidiana de
las personas con discapacidades en la
frontera colombo-venezolana en el sector
de arauquita la victoria si observamos
comunidades saliendo del territorio
venezolano tratando de salvaguardar sus
vidas 200 mil venezolanos cruzaron el
río arauca a finales de marzo y a
principios de abril para buscar refugio
al otro lado del río en colombia huyeron
debido a la intervención del ejército
venezolano en su región y el estado de
ocurrir para perseguir a los grupos
armados colombianos los habitantes que
nuestra redacción contactó en mayo
explicaron que habían abandonado
venezuela a causa de los bombardeos pero
también por miedo a que el ejército los
confunda con guerrilleros
fuimos debido a los bombardeos era
aterrorizante en el ripio los militares
robaron tiendas las casas fueron
quemadas y se me permite volver volveré
pero por el momento no se han retirado
las tropas del ejército venezolano
no podemos estar seguros de que el
conflicto se reanude dicen que los que
nos regresan son guerrilleros tenemos
miedo no queremos ser arrestados la ong
human rights watch tuvo acceso a
testimonios que confirman los abusos
cometidos por los militares la operación
lanzada por venezuela tiene como
objetivo enfrente décimo un grupo
disidente de las farc la ex guerrilla
colombiana 16 soldados murieron durante
esta operación y al menos 8 están en
manos de los rebeldes desde principios
de mayo la intensidad de los conflictos
ha disminuido y algunos desplazados han
regresado a sus hogares pero según el
experto regional bram abuso en las
tensiones en la zona fronteriza siguen
siendo fuertes
vemos que grupos armados han podido
penetrar estas zonas de frontera
pueden traficar bienes drogas dinero
armamento de un país al otro país
narcotraficantes usan venezuela como un
trampolín para acceder a mercados
internacionales y bien esos grupos
armados de la frontera aprovechando del
abandono estatal a ella están de camps a
ambos lados tanto en venezuela como en
colombia trabajan con personas locales
que no quieren acceso al mercado formal
de empleo y por lo tanto comunidades
están casi obligado a participar en
economías ilícitas de sus grupos armados
en apuré hay múltiples grupos armados
que están compitiendo en economías
ilícitas con grupos de steve estatales
que también participan en el
narcotráfico hacemos que la competencia
sea aumentado de tal forma que causó las
tensiones y por lo tanto en la fuerza
armada bolivariana exterior deshacerse
del actor armado que más molestaba esto
es el frente 10 de las farc
en tick tock personas con discapacidades
responden con vídeos a preguntas que les
hacen los usuarios para dar a conocer su
vida cotidiana y luchar contra los
prejuicios dos mujeres británicas luz y
edward que ciega james porque es
parapléjico explicarón como lo hacen
perdí la vista a los 17 años debido a
una rara enfermedad genética la
incontinencia pigmento es una manera muy
larga de decir soy totalmente ciega y vi
que había un vacío de conocimiento sobre
la ceguera en internet y me dije bien
puedo hacer vídeos muy cortos y
llamativos y llamar a la serie como lo
hace una chica ciega les aseguro que hay
mucha gente que no sabe cómo vivo mi
vida diaria
[Música]
bueno esto qué es
cuando empecé no había casi nadie que
hiciera vídeos sobre la discapacidad
diría a gritos y me parece que el
hashtag silla de ruedas tenía 11
publicaciones en instagram
hoy creo que superamos de largo las
100.000 publicaciones
es mi hija
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y mi vídeo favorito que he hecho en tick
tock es una chica ciegas y maquilladora
maquillarse suele ser una tarea muy
visual pero ya no lo es para mí y volvía
a tomar el control de mi apariencia
fallé y me levanté hayek y me levanté
inicialmente 'tik tok' había impedido
que los vídeos de personas con
discapacidades fueran incluidos en la
sección de sugerencias para ti es decir
estos vídeos no tenían ninguna
posibilidad de ser vistos masivamente
excepto quería proteger a las personas
con discapacidad de ser el blanco de un
posible acoso la plataforma se disculpó
cambió su política pero este episodio
deja un sabor amargo a nuestras
observadoras tenía miedo de utilizar
ciertas castas como discapacitados silla
de ruedas e lesión medular que necesito
usar si quiero que la gente encuentre mi
contenido pero obviamente tenía miedo de
usarlos porque temía que texto no
destacará el contenido que me había
esforzado en realizar
no sé qué está haciendo todo lo posible
para cambiar sus políticas y estoy en el
consejo de creadores de 'tik tok'
escuchar a los creadores así que sigan
observando porque el secretito que está
creciendo y cambiando cada día
y
y así terminamos nuestro programa por
esta semana si quiere escribir lea
nuestra reacción todos los contactos
aparecen en la pantalla envíenos sus
fotos y videos aficionado y quizá sea el
próximo observador de france 24 hasta
pronto
[Música]